an overview innovation platforms and I
recall from this morning's opening
question of who is in the room about
ninety percent of the room has had some
exposure to innovation platforms yeah
some just heard of it and others have a
fairly good grasp of it so we had a
definition of innovation in the morning
there's another one on the screen in
front of you as the process of technical
social and institutional change that
results from the interaction amongst
multi-layered sources of knowledge and
its transformation into new things
projects or practices applied in a
specific institutional and cultural
context very broad definition the
ingredients of innovations if you like
our dialogue ensuring incentive and
resources to develop businesses
reflection so that we can have double
loop learning and acting at various
levels it was mentioned in this
morning's presentation by Bernie that
Singapore has you know wonderful science
park and innovation networks and so on
but no agriculture yeah this is not a
phenomenon that's unique to agriculture
and in fact in industry and commerce we
find that quite a lot businesses get
together create science parks and
business hubs in order to bring similar
industries together and spur their
innovations so a lot of that revolves
around putting universities are in the
Institute's companies near markets and
letting them develop incubate idea
startup startups and also easy access to
enabling environment so access to
capital and good legal protection in
terms of patents and so on and so forth
and when you put that together your
start seeing a lot of growth in the
agricultural innovation system a lot is
borrowed from that so organizations and
individuals will come to
to generate the fuse and adopt new
knowledge so basically working together
pulling together delivering together
that's that's one of the mantras off of
this approach the innovation platform
can be physical or it can be virtual
it's essentially a form that's
established to facilitate the
interactions and learning amongst the
various stakeholders and it can be from
a commodity chain analysis or it can be
form a natural resource management but
there would be a topic that brings
people together people will will not and
frankly should not come together just
for the sake of it unless they have a
purpose that would not be very
sustainable yeah we have to work to
maintain interest so since ninety
percent of you have some exposure to the
topic I'd like you in small groups and
actually by small groups I mean groups
of two so turn around to your neighbor
and talk for it says five but will make
it to talk for two minutes about who
uses innovation platforms how do they
work and what process you typically find
and what are the main benefits and
constraints you don't have to cover all
four but talk about one of these four or
one or two of these for 42 minutes with
someone next to you group of three it's
okay sorry
so a quick question on who uses
innovation platforms who would like to
come in on that okay microphone please
all stakeholders okay which means what
the actors depart partners in the whole
system okay can you give some examples
researchers farmers policymakers private
sector market-driven thank you what
about what do they do how do they work
integrating the knowledge I mean
integrating the advances knowledge that
means innovation platforms okay thank
you very much somebody else add to that
in terms of how they work with somebody
else like to offer us more insights
maybe they have to walk between ended
after work in convergence partnership
collaboration cooperation and salsa yes
can somebody tell me what is the typical
constraints what are some of the typical
constraints of innovation platform
probably sometimes it's very difficult
to arrive in a certain conclusion given
period of time yes for instance what is
another constraint that can be linked to
that please use the microphone
probably conflict of interest yes we can
have conflicts of interest in these
groups can also be very expensive you
know and the group thing okay so you
have a problem whatever that problem
might be you come together so you start
the first thing that you do is you
initiate the platform and if you don't
have one then you together with the
platform decide on the focus yeah even
though I already had a problem here
we're still going to discuss it and
agree together on on the focus we then
are going to identify what the options
that are available to us to tackle that
we're going to then test and refine
solutions once we have our solutions we
might need to develop capacities in
order to be able to implement those
solutions and take them up to scale as
we're doing that we're going to analyze
and learn from our experience then the
cycle will go on yeah so this is a
typical model of an innovation platform
cycle you can look at that also in terms
of a breakdown of themes and issues to
reflect upon so you have one example
here in terms of composition
coordination power resource and
monitoring and specific sub issues that
you need to consider I'm not going to go
into all of those now but you'll have
them in your materials when you are
considering from a policy perspective
from an extension to to have one you can
use that as a checklist to think have we
given these matter of thoughts yeah and
I'm also going to provide you with a
number of alternative authors who have
looked at this and come came up with
different phases so some have six some
have seven some high five but they're
all extremely similar in in their
process it does not matter which one you
subscribe to it does matter that you
actually
one that you are following and checking
that you have a good checklist that
you're not forgetting critical steps
along the way especially if this is a
relatively new concept for the
organization that is promoting or
facilitating the platform it's a dynamic
process so the focus can change the
membership can change the
responsibilities can change just because
you met this morning to discuss what to
do with the forest between addison ababa
does not mean that that same group will
always and only work on that forest
issue yeah so it's important to keep
that in mind in terms of the process
that we follow some of the main benefits
is that it facilitates dialogues and
understanding and upward communication
it can help reach better informed
decisions it can also help make
innovative research possible which one
of these would you consider to be the
most enticing benefit so think now
really for from your own perspective
your organization if you go back and you
pitch your boss I want to us to
experiment with an innovation platform
approach what is the reason that you
find most enticing there's no right or
wrong here okay interesting so the room
is fairly split and all of these are
good reasons but the top reason from
this group do we have a tie in first
place between facilitating dialogue and
enabling innovative research yeah is
that because is that because you feel
that in your systems you're not seeing
enough of those this is a question that
I have when I see these results who is
thinking why is it the most important
but we're not here to only look at the
good and the beautiful we also need to
consider the constraints it's always
important because in the real world we
look at the trade-offs so some of the
constraints include that you really need
full buying from all
the members and that can be very
difficult and costly to implement and we
need tangible outputs to sustain members
and commitment this is especially true
when you want to involve farmers in the
private sector so I mean a farmer will
not continue to come to a meeting to sit
and discuss for the sake of it unless he
or she sees a tangible benefit yeah it's
usually researchers and government
officials who are more you know happy to
come and sit and talk but that's usually
because either they're doing research on
that so it's part of their work or
they're representing and that's also
part of the work but for other groups
you really have to make sure that
they're getting value for money this is
important because if you don't get that
people drop out and what that means is
that topics that don't give an immediate
benefit for example natural resource
management issues might have a harder
time sustaining innovation platforms
unless you link it directly to an
economic benefit which means that you
will need to be more aware of how you
address these issues it can also be
difficult to monitor and evaluate in a
systematic way it's about people coming
together sitting together talking right
how do you evaluate where is something
really happened maybe today there was a
breakthrough but it looks like just
every other meeting people SAT around
the table and talked so again my
question to you from the reasons which
are from the constraints which are on
the screen which one do you find the
biggest most crippling effect or
limitation of an innovation platform
okay here we have a clear decision which
is difficult and costly to implement
learning alliances piloted by the
central international who are equal to a
topical or the International Institute
for tropical agriculture based in cali
in Colombia in Latin America designed in
the early 2000s a solution for
challenges of out scaling it quickly
evolved into vehicles for strategic
Learning and capacity development and
there an approach for building
multi-stakeholder innovation systems so
essentially something very similar in
its origins and objectives to an
innovation platform if you look at the
definition that's on the screen
involving research donors development
policy makers bringing together to share
good practice it sounds very similar to
the definitions of innovation platforms
that we have been discussing so
essentially they are different names for
very very similar processes again at the
IP or learning alliance works at various
levels so you can work on it at the
local level at the methyl regional level
or the macro level
so when we talked about innovation
platforms originating in industry and
business but which part of the concept
that we see in business did not
necessarily translate translate well
into agriculture is it that a the aim of
improving the livelihoods of all
stakeholders be the involvement of
diverse sectors see sharing of knowledge
and technology or D the emphasis on
high-tech
yes overwhelmingly correct so an
innovation platform in agriculture does
not have to be about high tech and in
fact most of the time it's not about
Isaac which are the following positive
outcomes would you not anticipate from
an innovation platform or Learning
Alliance a increased number of patents
be greater relevance to farmers need see
mobility of knowledge tools and
approaches or D enhanced learning
only 18 okay yes you would typically not
expect to find patterns emerging out of
an innovation platform evening is there
much difference between so is there is
the statement says there is negligible
difference between an innovation
platform and a Learning Alliance would
you find this statement true or false
interesting
you want to do it again yes it's a true
statement yeah we just went over there
their main characteristics and we saw a
large amount of similarities in the
approach bringing over the multiple
actors working together to find solution
to spur innovation so it's very very
similar systems okay any open-ended
questions about module three the
innovation platforms